Recall how for caches we divided memory into blocks,
or cache lines. And this's the granularity at which
caching operates. Similarly, for a paging system we divide
up our physical address into pages, often 4k long.
Pages, are the granularity at which we grant memory
to processes. The higher order bytes determine the page
number, also called the physical page frame. And the
lower order bytes determine the offset into the page.
Correspondingly, the virtual address space is similarly divided into
pages. Again, lower order bytes determine the offset within
a page. The higher ones determine the virtual page
number. The number of bytes in the offset always match,
that's because virtual page sizes and physical page sizes
aren't necessarily the same. But, the number of bits involved
in the virtual page number need not match the
number of bits used to identify the physical frame number.
That's because, as we said before, it's possible to have more virtual pages
than physical pages. Since we're mapping
page for page between virtual and physical
addresses, the offsets stay the same. We do need to translate page numbers
however. And for this, we use a data structure called the Page Table.